هو المرعب الأول لإسرائيل
بعد هتلر،
وهو عدو الموساد الأول،
لقبوه بالأمير الأحمر
، وما أكثر ضحاياه في الموساد!
ولقب بصائد الجواسيس،
لم يمنعه ثراؤه من القتال ضد المحتل،
اخترق أصعب الأماكن التي استعصت على المقاومة،
صار الرجل الأمني الأول لفلسطين في الخارج،
تعرض للعديد من محاولات الاغتيال ،
وتمتع الأمير بشبكة علاقات دولية قوية،
(عن صياد الموساد الأحمر نتحدث وللقصة بقية )
تبدأ قصة علي أبو حسن سلامة،
الذي ولد، في عائلة ثرية جدا،
ولذلك لقبته إسرائيل بالأمير،
وهو في عمر الثامنة استشهد والده في حرب ١٩٤٨
كان والده أحد قادة جيش الجهاد المقدس،
نزحت عائلته إلى لبنان إلى مخيم شاتيلا،
ثم عادت بعد سنوات إلى رام الله
، ويقال أنه تلقى تدريبه العسكري مابين مصر وروسيا،
بعد ذلك أصبح ذا شعبية جارفة بين الشباب الفلسطيني،
وكان يحب اقتناء السيارات الرياضية ولأنه ثري فلم يمنعه شيء
من الحصول عليها، فلقبه الموساد الإسرائيلي بالأمير الأحمر
(الأمير لثرائه والأحمر  لكثرة الدماء التي أراقها منهم)،،
وفي عام ١٩٧٣ حاول الموساد اغتياله،
لكن أفراد العملية فشلوا في ذلك،
وتم عقاب أفراد الموساد الذين كانوا في العملية،
وبعدها توالت محاولات اغتياله مرة بعد أخرى،
لكنها باءت بالفشل جميعا،
قبل صعود الأمير الأحمر ليصبح اليد اليمين للرئيس ياسر عرفات،
حيث تولى قيادة العمليات الخاصة ضد المخابرات الإسرائيلية
في العالم من لبنان عام 1970.
كما يرتبط اسمه بالعديد من العمليات النوعية
مثل إرسال الطرود الناسفة من أمستردام
إلى العديد من عملاء الموساد في أوروبا،
بالإضافة إلى عملية ميونخ 1972
التي قامت بها منظمة أيلول الأسود،
خلال الألعاب الأولمبية، حيث اختطفت عددًا من رياضيي إسرائيل
وقتلت بعضًا منهم.  وأصبح بعد ذلك الرجل الأمني الأول
لفلسطين في الخارج،
أما عندما نعود لحياته الشخصية والاجتماعية،
فقد تزوج بامرأتين الأولى فلسطينية نشروان شريف منصور،
والثانية كانت ملكة جمال لبنان لعام ١٩٧١
وتدعى جورجينا رزق
وخلال عمل الأمير  كان يزداد الموساد الإسرائيلي كرها له
وخوفا منه خصوصا بعد معرفتهم بعلاقته بال CIA الأمريكي
، وكان الأمير على علاقة جيدة معهم لتسهيل الاتصالات
بين الفلسطينيين والولايات المتحدة الأمريكية لكسب دعمها للقضية الفلسطينية،
كما أقام صياد الموساد، علاقاتٍ مع مختلف أجهزة المخابرات الغربية
وذلك على الرغم من قيامه باغتيال عدد من ضباط
المخابرات الإسرائيلية حول العالم،
وكشف بعض عملاء الموساد في الوطن العربي
وخصوصًا لبنان، حيث كان له الفضل في القبض على
أمينة المفتي التي تجسست على الفصائل الفلسطينية
والتي كانت تعمل كطبيبة متطوعة
لكنها كانت تضع السم لجرحى المقاومة بدلا عن الدواء،
لصالح الموساد بعد أن قُتل زوجها على يد القوات السورية.
وكان الأمير يقوم بكل العمليات الأمنية التي تستعصي على المقاومة
والجهاز الأمني الفلسطيني في أي دولة في العالم،
كان علي سلامة معروفًا بنشاطاته القتالية،
لكن في الواقع لم يستطع أي شخص إثبات علاقته
بأي من العمليات القتالية التي أعلن مسؤوليته عنها
ولم يثبت أحد أنه هو قائد منظمة أيلول الأسود،
لذلك يعتبر قانونيًا بريئًا من كل التُهم التي تسببت في اغتياله.
(اغتيال الأمير)
عندما عجز الموساد عن اغتيال الأمير
، استعانوا بأحد عملائهم في بريطانيا ويدعى
(إريكا تشامبرس، وهو مواطن بريطاني،)
، فدخل العميل إلى الشرق الأوسط باسم جمعية خيرية
تدعم اللاجئين الفلسطينيين،  وعندما كان في لبنان،
حاول العميل معرفة نمط حياة الأمير ليرتب عملية لاغتياله،
لكن الأمير كان محميا من الحكومة اللبنانية،
ألا أن الأمير لم يكن مهتما بالإجراءت الأمنية المشددة
الخاصة به، وفي ال٢٢ من يناير عام ١٩٧٩
وبينما كان الأمير متوجها لوالدته لحفلة بيوم ميلاد،
واجه في الطريق سيارة  مفخخة جهزها العميل إريكا،
وعندما مشى الأمير  بجانب السيارة انفجرت العبوات الناسفة
التي فيها وكانت تقدر ب١٠٠كغ من المتفجرات،
أصيب الأمير بشظايا في جسده بالكامل وفي رأسه أيضا
كانت هناك العديد من الإصابات، وتم إسعافه إلى المستشفى
لكنه مات على سرير العمليات، كما توفي بجانبه مرافقوه الأربعة
وأربعة من المارة، وأصيب العديد ممن كانوا في منطقة العملية،
وبعد جنازة مهيبة، دفن علي أبو حسن سلامة بعد الصلاة عليه
وشيعه عشرات الآلاف من الفلسطينيين واللبنانيين
يتقدمهم الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل ياسر عرفات،
كانت رئيسة الوزراء الإسرائيلية غولدا مائير تقول
آتوني بهذا الوحش، أريد الأمير الأحمر حيا أو ميتا،
وقد حصلت على ما أرادت بموت الأمير لكن بعد أن أذاقها
ودولتها الأمرين وحصد العديد من أروح جنودها
ونفذ العديد من العمليات ضدهم،
فهل كان الأمير أسوأ أعداء الصهاينة في تاريخ الاحتلال؟...